yellowstone's prequel 1883 is rising to
success breaking records and satisfying
fans desires for more western drama but
how did it all get started which
celebrity couple stars in the show can
you watch it without seeing yellowstone
first keep watching find out the
yellowstone four season premiere half
the money gave viewers a tantalizing
glimpse into the history of the dutton
family and the yellowstone ranch an
extended flashback saw john dutton's
great great grandfather james dutton
along with two sons
the ancestral duttons encounter a group
of native americans who are seeking to
bury their own ancestor on the dutton
ranch that was once their home
unexpectedly the elder dutton accepts
their request and even offers them a
calf to help them get through the rough
winter it's an intriguing insight into
the beginnings of the dutton family and
gives backstory to some important
yellowstone moments notably john dutton
played by kevin costner has spoken of
his family's six generations on the
ranch and how they had vowed to never
let it go paramount and taylor sheridan
took that flashback and expanded it to
create 1883 the origin story of
yellowstone the new series introduces
james dutton again this time 10 years
before the scene we witnessed and half
the money here james has a daughter and
just one son with the other yet to be
born and we see them beginning the long
journey north to what will eventually
become their home in montana it remains
to be seen if we will see more direct
connections to yellowstone beyond the
early dutton pioneers however given the
history of the region we've heard from
the likes of john dutton and chief
rainwater on that series it's hard to
believe we won't
we've already seen some moments in 1883
that mirror parallel and give added
context to what we've seen on
yellowstone and we suspect that will
continue
speaking the deadline actor tim mcgraw
said it was the flashback scene shot for
yellowstone that got the ball rolling on
the spin-off after shooting the scenes
he received a call from series creator
taylor sheridan who suggested the studio
wanted a prequel but sharon wasn't given
a long lead time on the contrary
sheridan says the studio was so
impressed by the flashback to james
dutton that they wanted the new series
off the ground and airing by the end of
2021 they fast-tracked the series so it
could debut not long after the relaunch
of the studio streaming service now
rebranded as paramount plus sheridan
told deadline the studio read it april
12th and i was flying out may 2nd to go
film another tv show in another country
viacom cbs executive keys hill edgar
calls and says we can hang our hat on
this launch our streaming service with
it i say that's great he says we need it
this year i said keys that's not
possible i can start production in
february maybe he said no taylor we need
it to air this year sheridan wasn't
happy about the way the studio was
rushing production and pushed back
saying he needed more time it was
impossible to have something air in
seven months that wasn't cast with no
locations and no other scripts to make
it happen sheridan made demands of his
own saying i need the toys i need the
cast i need the team and i did not hear
the word no at all
the two central characters at the start
of 1883 are widower captain shea brennan
and the dedicated pinkerton agent thomas
they are the two men who are hired by a
group of german settlers to help them
travel north to find a new home but by
the end of the opener we meet the two
real stars of the series the ancestors
of yellowstone protagonist john dutton
delivering a pair of powerful
performances you'd think the leads were
hollywood veterans however those in the
know recognize him as country music
stars and husband and wife team of tim
mcgraw on faith hill while actor sam
elliott's as brennan brings the veteran
acting leadership to the cast mcgraw and
hill bringing crossover celebrity to the
series as both have individually become
icons in the music world they both have
dabbled in front of the camera with bit
parts here and there 1883 marks the
first time each will star on a leading
role in an interview with us magazine
hill spoke about what drew them to the
series comparing the decision to their
musical career saying
if the song is right then you don't give
it a second thoughts because writing is
a real craft that should be respected we
read the material and we were like how
can we not do it according to hill's
husband tim mcgraw the married couple
was always a package deal their latest
album 2017's the rest of our life was
their first joint musical effort and
1883 is the first time they team up on
the screen
i'm gonna build you a house so big you
get lost in it
yeah
more than just a spin-off of a hit
network drama 1883 is a sprawling
western epic that stands on its own the
connections to its parent series
yellowstone are definitely there and
fans of both series will be enriched by
watching them side by side even still
1883 is more than anything a
self-contained series about a family of
pioneers looking to make a new life for
themselves on the american frontier
though centered on the post-civil war
ancestors of the yellowstone family the
series also stars hollywood legend sam
elliott to shay brennan a man with no
connection to the prior series at least
none that we've seen thus far to his
credit series creator taylor sheridan
has crafted an origin story for his
prior series that requires no knowledge
of yellowstone it can be enjoyed all on
its own as a new period western set more
than 100 years before yellowstone
there's enough of a time gap that we
won't be seeing any familiar faces the
world of 1883 is a very different one
too with a lawless land of outlaws and
gunslingers although tonally these
elements may recall shades of the
neo-western yellowstone they offer up
very different opportunities for drama
the political landscape is also a stark
contrast to yellowstone with the west
largely unexplored and no corporations
or big business interests looking to
seize land from the duttons just yet
indeed 1883 has proven to be a very
different series more somber western
than family drama that said it's hard to
deny that watching both series won't
help weave a richer tapestry
production on the elaborate period
western wasn't an easy one and everyone
knew it going in actress faith hill told
the new york times once we committed to
the show we spent a lot of time speaking
to taylor sheridan and he was adamant
about this fact this is going to be
really really hard we're not afraid of
hard work but wow he was not joking it
was a challenging five-month shoot that
was still ongoing when the third episode
premiered on christmas day
the production headed to texas and
montana for much of the filming which
took place mostly outdoors and forced
the cast to endure harsh conditions
brutal winds and long hours in august
they had to contend with a 100 degree
heat wave while in montana it was a
single digit freeze despite the rough
conditions seriously tim mcgraw had no
regrets telling entertainment weekly
it's super dusty and super hot there's
no way around it at the same time it's
like every kid's fantasy to do something
like this put your chaps on your cowboy
hats and your gun holsters every day and
you get on a horse and try to survive
this journey
we warned you
actor lamonica garrett who plays
pinkerton agent thomas told deadline
about the difficult situations they were
in while filming saying there's a reason
they don't try things like this that
often and why lonesome dove was one of
the last ones it's difficult you're
traveling with all these wagons these
weather conditions the wind the river
crossing the horses but all seems to
have gone smoothly for the cast and crew
with sheridan saying fortunately no one
got hurt but it was a pretty dicey deal
its parent series yellowstone has been a
big hit and the first spinoff 1883 was
one of the most highly anticipated
streaming dramas of the year now the
numbers for paramount plus can back up
lofty claims made about the spin-off
1883 launched on the streaming service
on sunday december 19 2021 with the
first two episodes releasing the same
day the yellowstone sequel blew away all
previous debuts for the service setting
a new record for a paramount plus
original series premiere according to a
press release 1883 proved to be the most
watched debut for a new original and
more than doubled the previous record
holder in terms of viewership across the
services platforms the series premiere
was also broadcast following the week's
new episode of yellowstone as a standard
network broadcast and drew an additional
4.9 million estimated viewers
paramount's parent company viacom cbs
was clearly pleased with the launch too
tanya giles viacom cbs streaming
programming chief shared the results of
1883's debut are truly phenomenal the
day one streaming numbers coupled with
the results of the linear sampling
effort and social response from our
audience show the tremendous promise for
this series we look forward to
continuing on this epic journey with our
subscribers with yellowstone proving a
big hit in 1883 off to a fast start it
seems taylor sheridan's western
expansion may prove to be his own
manifest destiny
well i guess we're about to find out
ain't we
sam elliott has had roles in old
classics like virgil earp and the 90s
western crime drama tombstone and the
lead and the quick and the dead so why
would a big screen gunslinger like
elliot want to strap on the holster for
a tv series
talking to deadline the actor had a
pretty straightforward answer telling
them it was quote taylor's script series
creator taylor sheridan had made a name
for himself in hollywood with some of
the best thrillers in recent years eliot
was well aware of his reputation in
front of and behind the camera he said i
knew his work as an actor and because of
his films the guy writes brilliant stuff
i love his dialogue when initially
approached elliott wasn't without some
concerns mainly of his continued
typecasting in western saying you gotta
be careful i guess how many westerns you
do or they're going to think that's all
you can do still eliot was able to
overcome that concern thanks to sheridan
and the sterling script he received more
than won him over he told the new york
times in another interview his writing
is very spare that's a joy to work with
when you have dialogue that sounds like
people talk it's a lot of fun to do it
so far elliot has been impressed with
the finished product telling esquire
magazine that the end result has been
something special he shared i've never
seen one that has looked anything like
this on television for sure it looks
like a motion picture on the big screen
filming on location was important to
taylor sheridan to preserve the realism
of the visuals on screen he told
deadline we're not in studios it's not
five wagons that you know they cgi into
25 they're traveling with us for
sheridan authenticity was key to the
production veteran costume designer
janie bryant talked to the hollywood
reporter about her experiences and how
they made the cast believably dirty worn
and tired to look their parts bryant has
worked on several period dramas
including mad men and deadwood and those
programs were both good practice for her
experiences in 1883 she added the
actresses are all in corsets riding
horses or driving wagons and the men are
all in wool with the heat and the
elements and you can really feel how
taxing it was think about 100 degree
weather and wearing a camisole corset
bloomers bustle pad petticoats and then
putting a costume on top of that i
applaud them for going with it even the
way they produce the show harkens back
to days gone by sheridan told deadline
everywhere we go we exhaust all the
resources of whatever town we're in we
have like 400 cast and crew we're living
on a ranch no cable no cell service no
wi-fi speaking to the hollywood reporter
actor tim mcgraw praised sheridan's
dedication to the look and feel of the
series taylor is a stickler for
authenticity even to the way you ride
down to the set design and the costume
for sheridan if it wasn't a believable
world for the actors it wouldn't be for
the audience either
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]